u.s president joe biden has announced
american troops will leave afghanistan
nearly two weeks earlier than planned by
august 31st that's despite taliban
forces making
rapid advances across the country the
withdrawal will bring an end to the
longest u.s
war a nearly 20-year conflict but the
departure of nato troops is leaving many
worried about a swift deterioration of
security in afghanistan
[Applause]
the taliban say this footage shows them
celebrating after seizing control of a
key border crossing into iran
it was one of several advances made by
the militants throughout afghanistan in
recent weeks
they've been gaining ground since the
u.s announced the departure of its
military by the end of august
the same military that ousted them from
power in 2001.
[Music]
in washington president biden defended
the speed of the withdrawal
saying the u.s would no longer sustain
the human cost of a conflict
that cannot change afghanistan's course
so let me
ask those who want us to stay
how many more how many thousands more
americans daughters and sons
are you willing to risk i will not send
another generation of americans to war
in afghanistan
with no reasonable expectation of
achieving a different outcome
but biden also argued the u.s had
achieved its original goal of routing
al-qaeda
after the 9 11 terror attacks that led
to the invasion
he said the decision to leave was
overdue
we did not go to afghanistan to nation
build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people
alone to decide their future and how
they want to run their country
just days ago the u.s pulled out of
bagram air base near kabul
the center of its military operations
for nearly two decades
the pentagon says the withdrawal of u.s
forces is now more than 90 percent
complete
as foreign troops depart the afghan
military is struggling to push back the
taliban
like here in afghanistan's northwest
peace talks between the government and
the militants have so far
failed and many fear the violence will
only get worse
once the last u.s soldiers have returned
home
franz marty is a freelance journalist in
afghanistan he joins me now from the
capital kabul
france welcome the us troops leaving the
country and of course those
recent mainly rural gains made by the
taliban how likely
do you think it is that the entire
country could fall to the taliban
president biden timed this term this
scenario highly unlikely and i
as well as other knowledgeable analysts
agree this is not to say that the
situation
is not very dire as you said they have
made
unprecedented gains 150 plus districts
in the past a little bit over two months
that they have taken over however it is
noteworthy that so far they haven't
made a serious attempt to take over
provincial capital
this seems from the taliban side to be a
deliberate decision
um because they seem to now have the
strategy to take over rural areas
and um demand a surrender of the afghan
government
at the negotiating table uh and they
will pursue that
in the like foreseeable future as far as
it looks now
uh even if they would abandon this
strategy and would try
uh the advances have been so fast uh
there is a question whether the taliban
have enough enough manpower
to like actually take over everything
they might be able to take over several
provinces but
not uh swiftly the whole country um
in fact i have spoken by telephone to
people in like
newly conquered district and they told
me that barely any taliban are left
because they moved them
to the new front lines so that's why
fall of the whole country is still
unlikely at this time
right france after 20 years of
international support the afghan
national army is still not able to
completely defeat the taliban and
it seems not even really keep them at
bay can you explain why that is
uh there are several reasons and one
thing that is important to know
the us presence was already before
president biden announced a withdrawal
pretty small and they didn't do that
much so most operations were done
by afghan government forces so now that
they
uh lost that many districts seems to be
more uh psychological issue in many
districts
government forces abandoned them uh
without being like really forced by the
taliban it wasn't that they the taliban
have this overwhelming military power to
really force them out
um and then yeah several districts were
abandoned like that without apparently
uh due to a clear plan
um another thing is that like the
taliban as a geria movement
they have like an advantage in this
asymmetric warfare and
at the end reality is also in not in
significant parts of the population the
taliban have support
especially in rural areas so uh there it
is sometimes that the taliban have more
support than the government and that
allows them to to like make them the
advances
and makes it difficult for the afghan
government forces okay friends we're
running out of time but i really wanted
to get a sense
about the afghan people themselves i
mean are they happy to see the end of
foreign troops in their country or
is there a sense they're being let down
by the us and its allies
it's very split some people profited uh
from
from the u.s presence uh from the
progress that was made
they are worried they fear what will
happen um
if the americans leave completely and if
the taliban
move forward like this there are others
that have seen little
benefit of the progress uh that remain
like uh
very rural very uh traditionalist
and religious and they are uh happy that
that like
troops depart so it's like really it's
uh you have everything
right journalist franz marti in kabul
afghanistan thanks very much for the
analysis
you